parle pour mieux comprendre la situation
critique là bas j'en parle avec vous
docteur nathalie boulanger parce que
vous pratiquez depuis 30 ans dans le
nord-du-québec alors que vous nous
expliquer quelles sont les conséquences
de cette crise lancement les
conséquences ce que on ne peut s'occuper
que des urgences présentement donc toute
la vaccination le suivi des enfants
les suivi des maladies chroniques comme
le diabète les patients qui reviennent
de montréal avec des problèmes de santé
qui doivent qui nécessite un suivi plus
ou moins serré cemil côté complètement
c'est sûr que ça va avoir des
conséquences sur la santé de la
population qui est déjà précaire parce
qu'on a déjà acquis une population qui a
beau être jeune pardon qui a quand même
un état de santé beaucoup moins solide
que dans les populations qu'on retrouve
autour de montréal
que l'avion nous le groupe de médecins
on est on est inquiet de ça parce qu'on
se dit
qu'est ce qui nous attend à l'automne ce
qu'on va trouver des choses
épouvantables
dans l'est pas ça qu'on n'a pas réussi à
voir jusqu'à maintenant parce que
c'était pas d urgence de vivre marle des
choses que vous aurez pas pu
diagnostiquer atteint qu'est ce qui peut
expliquer en fait tout ce poème en
broutant médecins et d'infirmières à ce
que si les conditions difficiles les
salaires c'est quoi un peu de tout moi
ça fait 31 ans que je travaille au noir
on ne vit que dans ceux la pénurie puis
gérer les difficultés de recrutement et
de rétention personnel
honnêtement j'ai jamais vu ça aussi pire
que sort cette année
je pense que ça s'explique de plusieurs
façons oui c'est pas facile devez-vous
nunavik on n'a pas de réseau interne
mais le réseau internet y en a mais
c'est vraiment ces déficiences et
déficients il n'y a pas de cellulaire
c'est difficile de se rendre dans les
visages de lutte sont particulièrement
ya des problèmes d'approvisionnement en
eau et de deux pas encourageant financer
ces professionnels c'est çà et là
christian dubé va se rendre sur place on
l'a entendu est-ce que vous pensez que
ça va faire une différence que le
ministre la santé prennent la peine de
se déplacer moi je pense que c'est
toujours une bonne idée que un ministre
la santé bien visiter le nunavik parce
que ça ouvre les yeux c'est même si on
lui en parle même s'il fait des lectures
même s'il voit des photos c'est rien à
comparer à quand on met les pieds dans
l'hôpital puis on constate la betty cité
des lieux le manque de personnel les
gens qui ont l'air fatigué parce que ça
fait plusieurs mois qu'ils ont pas dormi
je pense que ça va être très positif de
ce côté là l'eau reste à savoir si
miraculeusement va être capable de
sortir ce saint firmin de sa poche en
trois jours je sais pas parce que vous
comme médecin vous avez besoin est des
infirmières parce que sinon vous vous
retrouvez à avoir beaucoup plus de
tâches à accomplir et ça devient un
stimulant pour les médecins le système
de santé où nous l'avait repose sur les
infirmières cliniciennes puis les
infirmières qu'on appelle l'art ou
l'élargir les infirmières ou l'élargisse
et des infirmières cliniciennes qui ont
à leur disposition un recueil dac
délégués
qui leur permet de diagnostiquer traiter
des conditions
assez courantes comme les autres titres
une infection urinaire des choses comme
ça quand il n'ya pas d'infirmière pour
faire ce travail là bien évidemment les
médecins doivent aller porter aide aux
infirmières alors le travail qui doivent
pas normalement
et pour compenser sans dubé parler d'un
plan de contingence qui entraîne se
mettra en place hier la croix rouge qui
veulent y participer
il faisait que des médecins des autres
provinces pour être envoyés en renfort
des ambulanciers ont dit paramédics sont
même en route est ce que vous croyez que
ça va fonctionner le plan de contingence
faudra plus que ça
le problème avec ça c'est que c'est pas
d'être on a besoin nombre pour vendredi
on est mercredi la croix rouge ça prend
du temps et non pas des infirmières qui
sont chez eux rien faire donc qu'ils
nous disent dans lieux déco ça va être
en septembre
les médecins qui viennent d'autres
provinces dans toute la complication
avec 400 permis de pratiquer au québec
est ce que tu parle français des
assurances quelque chose à part une
chose à faire c'est fake c'est sûr que
c'est possible que ça va se faire mais à
court terme à très court terme quand on
fait face à la possibilité d'être obligé
de fermer un autre un dispensaire qui de
dire à la population m'incite valeur si
vous avez un problème de santé ars
personne pour vous traitez
c'est sûr qu'à court terme des bonnes
soeurs des bonnes solutions à moyen
terme et à court terme ça nous donne peu
de choses c'est quoi les solutions à
long terme justement mais moi je pense
ça passe par une réorganisation du
travail là c'est la pénurie de personnel
est vécue à grandeur du québec un plomb
parlais tantôt lé mois la pénurie on
vieillit on vise haut depuis 30 ans mais
ce qui nous sauve est avancée qui avait
quand même bassin d'infirmières au sud
puis de médecins au sud qu'on était
capable de recruter temporairement mais
là c'est comme ça n'existe plus il y en
a plus les agences sont vides les
médecins sont tous occupés à travailler
ailleurs
donc faudrait l'armee justement l'a
remis à ce que c'est mais on n'a pas
besoin d'un régiment de l'armée on a
besoin de mettre d'infirmières surtout
plus de médecins puis le nombre dont on
a besoin c'est pas 30-40 clos une
poignée de monde qu'on a besoin pour
être en mesure de donner les services
même dans les plus grosses dispensaire
où les plus gros clsc les infirmières
qui font la première ligne sont peu
nombreuses la réforme ceux des fois ils
sont six mais souvent son cas là qu'on
comprend que sita manque 2 sur 4 2 50%
de ta force de travail qui vient de
partir que c'est pour ça qu'on tombera
en rupture de service facilement les
médecins c'est la même chose moi j'ai
deux médecins qui travaillent j'ai deux
postes de médecins qui travaillent à sa
louise
si jamais il était trop c'est trop mais
quand ils sont un ton post fils s'est
passé
si c'est difficile aussi de prévoir ou
dire on va on va engager plus au corps
où on aurait on aurait pas de place papa
tu l'as on aurait besoin donc si
beaucoup de travail quand même qu
attendent ministre dubé est là pour
corriger cette situation là et vous vous
êtes quand même continuer travailler sur
place vous êtes quand même motivé oui
maman car et au nunavik ça fait je
serais parti le plus longtemps moi je
trouve que c'est la plus belle pratique
au monde là de travailler avec les
populations autochtones dans les petits
villages aussi où tout finit par
connaître tout le monde le voit dans le
village où j'ai pratiqué le plus
longtemps y a personne que je connais
pas quand je vois un patient ben je
connais sa mère sa grand mère ça fait
des liens que se retrouve pas ailleurs
admirable entre merci beaucoup puis je
vous souhaite un bon retour nous l'avons
on dîne avec en espérant justement que
ça fasse une différence que le ministre
se rende sur place merci beaucoup